When I was thinking about the future development of the Japan series,
I started considering a worldview that was not Japan during the Sengoku period.
We started to consider the concept of Chinese mythology with thousands of years of history
and technology unique to the age of the five
senses.
Ball's policy was started after judging that it could be a
concept.For this work, the dark world view
makes it easy to recall powerful enemies and harsh environments, and
is
an important element in order to give a sense of accomplishment when overcoming them.
Also, the world of Sangokushi is an era of turmoil
that is rare even in the world market,
and I wanted to depict it head-on
.
The battles of this work are characterized by the elegant and speedy actions typical of Chinese martial arts
We are aiming for a sense of coexistence of such tension and exhilaration that is dominated by splendid action.It
is necessary for the player to be satisfied with the operation and the result, so
the feel of the hand, which is also the focus of the number of teams, is
particularly important.
[Music] In
character creation, the player
can play with the look they want, so they can be more immersed in the game,
and
especially in titles like Orlon, playing
so that their favorite character doesn't die
is one of the big
motivations.
Also, in online play, etc.,
there will be a lot of variation in appearance between players, so I think that
the value of gameplay is also mass due to this.
For that reason, by
not placing the main character as a specific character
, there are fewer restrictions in terms of situations and productions,
and the relationship with various warlords that appear in Sangokushi
can be depicted.  I think it's an advantage that it's easy to draw a
lot of scenes where the main character plays an active part in a hidden battle scene.
I think it's because it's an emotion that you can't easily experience in a game. If the
trial and error process is not unreasonable,
but
has a high degree of freedom and is fair, it will
be a title that many players like as an experience that doesn't cost money
.  I feel that the
forward route is not a game with a friendly name
, but we are promoting policies so
that you can feel the experience and
sense of accomplishment that is unique to this title.  At the TGS venue, you can enjoy
5 different play styles with different weapons and tactics,
so please try to find the play style
that suits you.
I think the point is how
to raise the formula.The key to strategy is whether you dare to challenge a formidable enemy in order to raise the formula on a large scale, or
whether to go steady and how to suppress the cleansing.
[music]
[applause]